♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE EXTREME RADICAL
2020 SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS ARE
GETTING TOO RADICAL FOR THEIR
PARTNERS, THEIR BEST FRIENDS AND
THEY HATE TRUMP MEDIA MOB.
CHRIS MATTHEWS, SOUND THE ALARM.
MAY BE SURE AND TELL PEOPLE HOW
YOU REALLY FEEL, HIDE IT LIKE
YOU USED TO DO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> I DON'T SEE HOW HE WINS AGAIN
WITH THE NUMBERS HE HAS.
>> HAVE YOU SEEN WITH THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING?
>> YOU CAN'T BEAT SOMEBODY WITH
NOBODY.
>> THEY ARE RESISTING.
GOING TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARIES IS NOT THE SAME AS
GOING TO THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA REPORTER
WITH THE HILL AND W OF 0, THE
HOST THE WORLD WINNING
JOURNALIST LAURA LOGAN.
WE HAVE LIVED THROUGH THIS
BEFORE.
BARACK OBAMA MANIA.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THAT THEY
ARE PUSHING HARDER TO THE LEFT.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN STOP THAT,
DO YOU?
>> I'M NOT A POLITICIAN AND NOT
A POLITICAL REPORTER.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER YOU CAN
STOP IT OR NOT.
MY CONCERN AS A JOURNALIST IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
FACTS ARE.
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY REPRESENTING AND
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IN THE
ELECTION.
AS JOURNALISTS IT SEEMS TO ME,
OUR JOB IS TO DO THAT.
THAT IS OUR DUTY.
I REALLY WANT TO KNOW, ARE THE
OPINION HOUSE?
ARE THESE OPINION SHOWS FOR NEWS
PROGRAMS?
THAT IS A IMPORTANT DISTINCTION.
WHAT PEOPLE TELL ME IN AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT
TO KNOW.
WHEN THEY TURN ON THE NEWS THEY
WANT THE FACTS.
WHEN THEY TURN ON AN OPINION
SHOW LIKE YEARS THEY WANT YOUR
OPINION.
WHERE DO THESE PEOPLE STAND?
>> Sean: I AM A RADIO AND TV
TALK SHOW HOST.
I HAVE HUNDREDS OF HOURS I CAN
PRODUCE SUBSTRATE REPORTING.
A SHOOTING WAR, NATIONAL TO MIKE
DISASTER.
HISTORY PREFORMING.
WE DO INVESTIGATIVE WORK, THEY
ARE TOO LAZY AND PARTISAN TO DO
AND WE DO OPINION AND SOMETIMES
PORTS.
SOMETIMES CULTURAL ISSUES, WE
ARE LIKE A HOLE'S PAPER.
THAT IS MY ROLE.
IS THAT FAIR?
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE MERELY TO
AN END FOR YOUR OPINIONS, BUT
YOU COVER LOTS OF STUFF.
>> Sean: I COULD PRODUCE
HUNDREDS OF HOURS.
>> THAT IS FINE.
MOST OF THE TIME PEOPLE WANT TO
KNOW YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON A
CERTAIN NEWS.
>> Sean: DO YOU WANT MY
OPINION OR SOMETHING THAT IS WAS
BREAKING LIKE ROCKETS AND ISRAE
ISRAEL?
>> I CAN ASK YOUR QUESTION.
ON THE CNN WEBSITE, THEY ARE
LISTED AS ANCHORS AND CLEARLY
THEY ARE GIVING OPINIONS AND YOU
JUST SHOWED ONE.
AS FAR AS THEY LEFT TALKING
ABOUT HIS WORRY THAT THE PARTY
IS GOING TO FAR LEFT, POLITICO
HAD A GOOD STORY LAST MONTH THAT
TALKED ABOUT --
THIS WASN'T SOMEONE'S OPINION.
ECONOMIC MODELS WITH STRONG
TRACK RECORDS AND PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS.
THEY SAID THE RISING ECONOMY,
LOW GAS PRICES, AN ADVANTAGE
HELD BY AN INCUMBENT.
THEY SAY IF YOU LOOK AT ALL
THOSE FACTORS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL WIN IN A LANDSLIDE.
I DON'T THINK WE ARE IN A
LANDSLIDE CULTURE ANYMORE, BUT
BASED ON THAT ALONE AND THE
THOUGHT THAT DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
WITH MEDICARE FOR ALL,
ELIMINATING THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
MORE REGULATIONS, ALL THOSE
THINGS AND EXPANDING THE
SUPREME COURT.
ALL OF THOSE IDEAS WILL BE
REJECTED BY THE ONE PART OF THE
DEBATE THAT MATTERS MOST.
>> Sean: YOU ARE ON
"60 MINUTES," THIS --
I DON'T SEE THAT ANYMORE.
I DON'T SEE 60 MINUTES BECAUSE
THEY TAKE YOU FOR TEN HOURS AND
CHOP IT DOWN TO 15 MINUTES.
THAT IS CALLED EDITING FAKE
NEWS.
>> THAT HAPPENS AND I HAVE TO
SAY JOE, THAT ANCHOR DOESN'T
ANSWER MY QUESTION.
AS AN ORGANIZATION, WHERE DOES
CNN STAND?
HAVE YOU TAKEN A POLITICAL
POSITION OR HAVE YOU NOT?
THE PROBLEM WITH WHAT HAS BEEN